plus de 20 km de file d'attente pour
passer en Géorgie
dans ces milliers de voitures des Russes
fuyant la mobilisation des réservistes
décrétée par Vladimir Poutine
les voici enfin côté Géorgiens après
deux à trois jours dans bouteille
nous les retrouvons à BBC la capitale du
pays nouvelle file d'attente pour se
procurer une carte SIM et téléphoner
localement
valez sur le trottoir ces hommes
expliquent que jusqu'à présent les
Russes laissent passer presque tout le
monde moyennant parfois des peaux de vin
jusqu'à 180 euros souvent ces hommes
disent qu'ils n'ont pas encore été
convoqués par les autorités militaires
mais ils partent par précaution
c'est allé trop loin ce que nous propose
le gouvernement ne me convient pas on a
deux solutions soit on est mobilisé on
va au front soit on va en prison si on
refuse
bien sûr tout le monde ne sera pas
mobilisé mais tu ne sais pas si ça va
tomber sur toi ou sur quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai peur que la situation a réussi se
dégrade qu'il n'y ait plus du tout
d'emploi par exemple
eux aussi arrivés récemment l'un était
en voyage professionnel au moment de
l'annonce de la mobilisation l'autre en
vacances en Géorgie tous les deux
viennent de décider de s'installer à BBC
il raconte ce que vivent leurs amis
restez en Russie
tout se demande comment se cacher
comment éviter la mobilisation comment
contourner les bureaux de recrutement
militaire comment sortir le moins
possible ne pas prendre le métro par
exemple parce qu'il y a des caméras de
surveillance
ne sont pas forcément les bienvenus en
Géorgie sur ce graffiti récent ils sont
invités avec des mots assez crus à
rentrer chez eux